I think, personally, everything that can be easily
automated is eventually going to be automated
in the construction industry.
And automation--I use the term "robot" kind of
interchangeably for "automation."
So for the purpose of this talk please,
give me that and not get too technical about it.
But it's kind of equivalent to automation in general.
And also I'm honestly really talking about
for all intents and purposes weak AI.
I'm not getting into crazy singularity strong AI,
what the future could be like a thousand years
from now. Okay? So this is today.
Today robots do my drafting.
So I don't draft things anymore.
There's a whole new thing that came out, started using about 10 years ago.
This concept called BIM which is Building Information Modeling.
I'm not going to get too technical here.
But the basic idea is-- see that top left there?
That's an image of the 3D model of one of the buildings
at the UCSF Medical Center, the new medical buildings.
They are giant machines wrapped in a pretty skin.
So that they're not scary to us people when we go there.
Like seriously, they're incredibly complex.
So trying to navigate that kind of a project with
2D drawings on paper
is almost impossible.
This whole BIM system basically what you do is
you describe to the computer in high detail
what the building is made out of
and then that system then produces
a lot of the drawings, plans, sections, elevations...
all that kind of stuff you need
to submit to the building department.
So robots are already doing our drafting.
Robots are also doing our field measuring.
This is a laser scan of a city square in Europe.
With the Wunderkammer cabinet under the stairs here,
we actually had a point cloud of the interior space
that somebody had done. And we were able to
take the laser measurements of that.
And use that to fabricate the cabinet.
And the other thing is this whole idea that
...this is from our friend's company
Tyler, raise your hand?
(he works for that company)
This whole idea that it's more about data
than it is about drawing.
And also robots build my building.
So there's this whole concept called digital fabrication
Where we have these computer-controlled tools
that cut things out.
So the things I draw on a computer, that I
model on a computer: these giant robots will then
carve or cut out those pieces for me.
That's how everything you see in here was made.
We didn't cut out that cabinet.
That cabinet was cut out for us by a robot.
Another really interesting thing--
This is our... one of our CNC machines.
We have one of the older ones here.
So this is what I'm talking about.
It's a giant cutting robot. In the top corner there,
that's something called a Total Station.
It's a really exciting new thing
that's come into existence the last 10 years or so.
So they started making survey equipment
for job sites robotic.
So that one guy could just walk around with a little wand
and GPS mark points, right?
And then they're like well if that thing's robotic
why don't we put appointing laser on it?
And it can point where stuff's supposed to go.
So you feed the CAD model to it and it will
point with a laser, like:
Oh yeah the anchors for the pipes that you're
going to hang in 6 months from now go there and
there and there and there...
And so it created a feedback loop.
Because you can measure things on the site, too,
with that and then feed it back in the CAD model,
back in the BIM model.
So if something got put in the wrong place
you know exactly where it's at, and you can coordinate
and all that kind of stuff.
This is all stuff that's happening today.
This is not hoo-ha future, this is
really standard kind of stuff.
Prefabrication and pre-production,
I'm not talking about the kind of hyped up Dwell like
we're going to drop a house on a site
kind of prefabrication. But like bathrooms now
are something on larger commercial projects
where they're just fabricating those bathrooms
as little units in a factory and
just bringing them out and dropping them
into the site with a crane.
Also the new Apple campus, the new buildings
they're building on the Apple campus.
A bunch of the offices and bathrooms are all
getting prefabricated in some fancy factory somewhere,
brought onto the jobsite, dropped in place.
And a lot of that is heavily automated in those factories.
And then lastly, this is a bit of a joke,
but there are robotic bulldozers now.
Robotic bulldozers look exactly like normal bulldozers
which is why I put this picture in there instead.
But basically there are systems now where you
feed it the CAD data of what the site is supposed to be.
And a driver just follows a line on a screen
on a GPS. And the blade of the bulldozer
automatically moves to grade the site to make it
have the shape that it needs to have.
And they've been doing that
for like 8 years now or something.
Trimble that has that whole front to back setup.
It's pretty awesome stuff.